since it premiered on HBO in the spring
of 2011 Game of Thrones has become a
worldwide smash many stars of the show
of skyrocketed to fame but over the
course of making the series they've also
encountered some unexpected hardships
here's a look at some scary tricky and
grueling sacrifices actors had to make
for Game of Thrones in her years of
playing Sansa Stark sophie Turner has
endured arranged marriages sexual
violence and the loss of loved ones
though Sansa began the show is a spoiled
child who wanted nothing more than to be
a princess she has grown into a shrewd
warrior Turner hasn't personally been
through the horrors that Sansa has but
she's endured her fair share of
difficulties including an unhygenic
request after Sansa escaped from King's
Landing
Turner was asked to stop washing her
hair so she would look as disheveled as
possible during sonses darkest times
it wasn't an enjoyable experience for
Turner she said it was really disgusting
now I wear a wig so I can wash my hair
whenever I want which is nice but yes
for a couple of years I was living with
pretty greasy hair one of the show's
all-time hardest scenes to watch has to
be the red wedding near the end of the
third season Robb Stark betrays his
promise to marry the daughter of one of
his allies Walder Frey so the Freys
slaughter Rob his pregnant bride to Lisa
and his mother Catelyn none of the
actors involved in the red wedding were
particularly excited about filming the
sequence but Oona Chaplin who played to
Lisa
had it really been after her pregnant
character is repeatedly stabbed in the
stomach she's left on the floor to
torment Rob Chaplin spent hours lying on
a floor in a cold Belfast studio she was
freezing and covered in fake blood while
she waited for the rest of the cast to
finish their scenes Chaplin's commitment
can't be understated in the 7th season
of Game of Thrones several characters
who hadn't yet met came together with
varying results when Daenerys Targaryen
met Jamie Lannister for the first time
it didn't go very well during their
battle bran Jaime's right-hand man must
operate an enormous spear launcher to
fight against Daenerys dragon drogon
though Bronn does get one good hit in
against drogon the machine is quickly
burned to ashes
bran survives but gets caught in the
flames druggin spends most of the scene
setting fire to the battlefield all the
actors had to contend with smoke
inhalation but Jerome Flynn who plays
bran got the worst of it
director of photography Robert
McLaughlin burned diesel oil for
dramatic black smoke most of the crew
wore masks Flynn had to go unmasked and
it's hard to miss the discomfort visible
on his face
the Battle of the bastards which took
place during the show's sixth season was
the combination of a long chain of
events that included jon snow's reunion
with his sister Sansa her escape from
her sociopathic husband Ramsay Bolton
and the long-awaited showdown among them
all as with many battles on Game of
Thrones each moment is more brutal than
the last and throughout the fight it
seems unlikely that Jon Snow will emerge
victorious
at one point he ends up submerged in a
pile of dead bodies and living soldiers
gasping for breath as he struggles to
rise to the surface which reportedly
terrified actor Kit Harington
who plays snow he didn't enjoy this part
of the filming as being crushed is one
of his biggest fears he gave up his own
comfort to create a singular moment for
viewers speaking of Ramsay Bolton when
viewers met the character played by E
one rien in season three he was a
bastard much like Jon Snow when he
helped his father Roose Bolton secure
the north he was made an official Bolton
in his own right
after watching Ramsay generally be the
worst person of all time fans were
thrilled when Ramsay met a bitter and
bloody end in the aftermath of the
Battle of the bastards it was especially
satisfying to hear him being torn apart
by his own pack of angry attack dogs but
before that goes down once the larger
battle ends Jon and Ramsay find
themselves back at Winterfell ready to
keep fighting Jon snaps and brutally
beats Ramsay into submission however
some of this ended up becoming a reality
for Rhea who was actually punched in the
face twice by Harrington Harrington said
Rhian was extremely nice about the
situation but it's unlikely that Ryan
was thrilled about
taking two for the team since they
viewing on the show during season two
Brienne of Tarth played by actress
Gwendoline Christie has won audiences
hearts with her fierce battle skills
unerring loyalty and quick quips after
serving a few fallen characters
including Catelyn Stark Brienne strikes
up a real friendship with Jaime
Lannister between her bond with the
Kingslayer and her continued devotion to
Catelyn Brienne has become a fan
favorite
as such fans are always frightened when
Brianna ends up in a life-threatening
situation when Brienne and Jaime are
captured and held hostage by Locke a
hunter for house Bolton Locke forces
Brienne to face down a real bear in a
fighting pit causing Jaime to come in
and rescue her
although Christy said the bear was a
diva requiring its own trailer she also
said it was terrifying to face down the
giant animal with nothing more than an
electric fence between them few of
Thrones villains have elicited a public
reaction quite as visceral as Joffrey
Baratheon the sadistic eldest son of
Cersei Lannister a bitter violence
hungry child born of incest
King Joffrey's vengeful and ill-advised
decision to execute Ned Stark in the
show's first season set off most of the
entire story's conflict so long as I'm
your king treason shall never go
unpunished
so in it bring me his head viewers have
watched him murder sex workers
threatened to beat women and verbally
abuse pretty much everyone
it's no wonder viewers loved watching
Joffrey get slapped he meets an
extremely ugly end early in the fourth
season during his wedding to Margaery
Tyrell Joffrey takes a final sip of wine
gruesomely choking to death in front of
the entire court actor Jack Gleeson quit
acting after his last moments as Joffrey
he said that aside from the choking
itself keeping his eyes open was the
hardest part they actually had to be
held open so he didn't blink
making filming the scene that much more
uncomfortable Cersei Lannister yet
another Thrones character that viewers
love to hate has committed her fair
share of atrocities
you know stuff like enabling her evil
son Joffrey carrying on a decades-long
affair with her twin brother and
slaughtering most of King's Landing by
burning them with wildfire she got her
just desserts for some of her crimes at
the end of the show's fifth season when
she was forced to take a walk of
atonement through King's Landing
completely naked while the townspeople
verbally and physically abused her the
walk was shot in Dubrovnik Croatia near
an ancient church the production was
nearly banned however due to the nudity
in the end actress Lena Headey asked for
a body double thanks to the magic of
visual effects Rebekah van Cleves body
stood in for Circe's Van Cleave spent
three days walking the streets of
Dubrovnik completely naked while crew
members and extras shouted and lted her
with food van Cleves face was never
shown after a number of shocking deaths
throughout Thrones run viewers have
accepted the idea that nobody is safe
which made Jon Snow's false start of a
death all the more horrified
during the season 5 finale Jon now the
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch is
betrayed by his men and repeatedly
stabbed over accusations of treason the
show cuts to black leaving anxious fans
without answers regarding Jon's fate
until the next season premiere actor Kit
Harington told various media outlets he
would not be returning to the show which
turned out to be a pretty enormous lie
Jon was alive and well by the second
episode of the next season Harrington
reportedly hated lying with huge fans
like President Barack Obama concerned
about Jon Snow's fate Harrington had to
play it extremely safe for over a year
he did get himself out of a speeding
ticket by revealing one of the show's
biggest spoilers to an anxious police
officer so at least there was some
silver lining to this sacrifice I looked
at everyone I'm alive next season honey
Josie says mm-hmm on your way Lou come
on throughout Game of Thrones run Arya
Stark has transformed from a young
impetuous would-be warrior to a truly
dangerous faceless assassin
after watching her father's public
execution and making the journey from
Westeros to the house of the undying in
Braavos she agrees to learn from the
mysterious face changer shuckin hogar
she waits outside the house for days to
earn her place inside as soon as arya
learns how to change faces she uses her
power to kill Mervyn Trent but because
it wasn't yet merwin turn to die arya is
punished by Xhaka
who blinds her and forces her to live as
a beggar while blind
Arya's eyes are clouded unfortunately
for actress Maisie Williams the contacts
were quite thick and hand-painted
actually obscuring her vision Williams
admitted that while she didn't want to
complain her blind scenes left her in a
significant amount of pain she's stuck
with it ensuring that each shot during
arias blind phase was exactly right
Theon Greyjoy the once cocky heir to the
Iron Islands has been through his fair
share of ordeals once a young stubborn
ward of the north Theon was initially
loyal to Robb Stark in the wake of Ned's
death eventually he betrayed robb and
was captured by the sadistic Ramsay
Bolton who physically and
psychologically destroyed the on until
he referred to himself as reek perhaps
the hardest scenes for actor Alfie Allen
to endure throughout Thrones were his
torture scenes with Ramsay he spent most
of the full season strung up savagely
mutilated and beaten it can't have been
easy for Allen to even pretend to be
tortured and he has since spoken out
about how hard it was to play he watched
movies that prominently featured torture
including Quentin Tarantino's bloody
classic Reservoir Dogs spending so much
time with in this unflinchingly terrible
part of Theon story must have been
incredibly difficult for Allen some
viewers might have forgotten about
Lancel Lannister played by Eugene Simon
when audiences meet a young girl Ansel
he is a seemingly innocent Squire to
King Robert until the Monarchs death
after an ill-advised affair with his
cousin Cersei which is somehow not the
grossest relationship she has in the
show Lancel is severely wounded in
season two's Battle of Blackwater Bay
and
to the sidelines when Lancel returns
he's joined an oppressive and severe
religious sect called the sparrows when
Lancel spills the beans about his
relationship with Circe she gets angrier
than ever
rather than attend her own trial the
vengeful queen mother unleashes a
magical wildfire throughout King's
Landing killing numerous people Lancel
sent to find the missing Circe during
her trial discovers her plan he can't
stop the explosion in time despite his
best efforts
Simon spent hours crawling through a
dark dungeon in during the journey a
whopping 27 times until they got the
shot right check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]